[Music]  everybody's kind of mandated to stay  home therefore  the majority of restaurants are closed  or limited to  space sitting so therefore now we're  only doing two goals  for this week we open back up on friday  a lot of customers have decided to just  go ahead and come pick it up  it's already a stressful time we make it  convenient and easier for them  in the previous years they had picked  they chose to pick it up on wednesday  and thursday  this time they were really ready to come  monday to avoid the line it's different  and we're gonna try virtual this year  but it's it's not really like what we  used to  i ordered the turkey ultimate turkey  package  and it's a whole turkey with sides and  an apple pie we usually we have a big  feast  travel to l.a but this year we're  staying put  we have family in town so we're just  gonna have a little  little tiny thanksgiving this year